what do you think is the meaning
of life this individual life of ours
your life
that unfortunately has to come to an end
as far as we know for now
yeah um and our life here together
is there a why or do we just kind of
like let our curiosity carry us away
oh interesting is there a
single kind of driving purpose why or
can it just be curiosity-based
i certainly feel and this is not the
scientist in me talking but just more of
like a human soul talking
i certainly feel some sense
of
purpose and meaning in my life and
there's a version of that that's a very
local level within my family which is
funny because this whole conversation
has been big grand space exploration
themes but you asked me this question
and my first thought is what really
matters to me my family my
biological reproducing unit
um
but then there's also another purpose
like another version of the meaning in
my life that is trying to do good things
for humanity so that sense that we can
be individual humans and have our local
meaning and we can also be global humans
maybe someday like the star trek utopia
will all be global citizens
i don't want to sound too
naive um
but there is i think that beauty to a
meaning and a purpose of your life
that's bigger than yourself
working on something that's bigger and
grander than just yourself
the deepest meaning is from the local
biological reproduction unit and then it
goes to the engineering scientific um
what is it corporate like company unit
that can actually produce and compete
and interact with the world and then
there's the the giant human unit that's
struggling with pandemics and commons
and and together struggling against the
forces of nature that keeps wanting to
kill us yeah there'd be nothing like an
alien invasion to unite the planet we
think
i can't wait bring it on aliens uh
listen your your work you're an
incredible communicator incredible young
scientist there it's huge honor that you
would spend your time with me i can't
wait what you do
uh in the future and um thank you for
representing mit so beautifully so
masterfully you're an incredible person
thank you for talking thank you so much
for having me it's been an absolute
pleasure it's a great conversation
you